and staying in the u.s we are just
getting some breaking news now that the
governor
of new york state andrew cuomo has just
resigned he had been under intense
pressure after the
state's attorney general alleged that he
had sexually harassed
multiple women this is the moment he
announced his resignation
the best way i can help now
is if i step aside and let government
get back to governing
and therefore that's what i'll do
because i
work for you and doing the right thing
is doing the right thing for you
because as we say it's not about me it's
about
me all right so uh
new york governor andrew cuomo
announcing there that he would
resign as governor uh
democratic governor of the third largest
state
uh in uh the u.s something of a surprise
this
announcement because uh up until this
moment all the indications
were that he was uh that he was he was
not going anywhere and he would continue
to stay as governor but
there were of course plans by the state
legislature
in in new york to move ahead with his uh
impeachment but that will not that will
not happen
presumably because he has now announced
that he will uh resign we hope to have
we're going to listen in more to a
little bit more of that now as the
governor cuomo is still speaking live
now no one thought we could do it
but you did it you led the nation
and you showed the way forward and how
you did it
is what's most important you did it
together
not as black new yorkers or white new
yorkers not as lgbtq new yorkers or
straight new yorkers or democrats or
republicans or upstate or downstate or
jewish
muslim protestant or catholic new
yorkers but as one community
one family the family of new york
you overcame the naysayers and the
haters
and the fear and the division and you
unified
and you rose and you overcame and you
saved
lives and that was powerful in its
effect
it was beautiful to see and it was an
honor to lead please
remember that lesson hold it dear
and hold it up high for this nation to
see
because it is new york state at her
finest
creating her legacy fulfilling her
destiny
giving life and animation to the lady in
the harbor
saying excelsior we can be
better we can reach higher
and proclaiming e pluribus unum
out of many one unity
community love
that is our founding premise
and our enduring promise
and that is the salvation of this nation
that it so desperately needs to hear
thank you for the honor of serving
you it has been the honor of my lifetime
god bless you new york governor andrew
cuomo
uh in a televised address just there
moments after announcing
uh that he would resign as governor of
the state of new york
effective 14 days from now let's go live
to kristin salumi
who is in new york uh for force
for us with more reaction on this
kristen something of a surprise here
it is something of a surprise he has
been
vigorously defending himself andrew
cuomo against
allegations of sexual harassment among
staff members
11 of them have come forward and gave
their accounts of what they considered
abusive behavior to the state attorney
general the attorney general compiled
a lengthy report and found that there
was evidence to support their claims
this has launched
several investigations by local justice
officials here in new york but
the governor has at the same time
apologized and denied that he did
anything wrong he
uh i should say he admitted that he
acted insensitively
uh he admitted that he is a very touchy
feely kind of a governor he
uh would kiss people hug them
uh in the days leading up to this he
provided pictures of him doing this at
events all around the state
but the pressure was growing against
andrew cuomo
members of his own party in which he was
considered until very recently a rising
star with
national aspirations one by one we're
stepping away from him
and calling the situation in albany new
york's capital
untenable and the governor himself just
admitted that he came out and he said
while
it was his instinct as a new yorker to
keep on fighting
that this was becoming too much of a
distraction from
state business which includes the
ongoing fight against the coronavirus
among
many other priorities and and he said
that the impeachment process
investigation which had been launched by
state lawmakers
would take too long cost too much money
and
detract from uh what
the people of new york needed from their
government and
and with that uh attempted to both
defend himself
uh but also step down and step away and
is there a sense then then in making
this decision
a question perhaps he felt that he was
uh
too much of a of a burden uh
not only on the people around him and
but also the democratic party and and
and how that affected their standing uh
nationally
well absolutely andrew cuomo has become
a
punching bag for the right in the united
states
his handling of the coronavirus while
very popular on the east coast and in
new york
uh had come under criticism for his
handling of nursing homes in particular
he had become a bit of a lightning rod
nationally
and locally um because of that and
because
of these allegations against him of
course he is representing the democratic
party which has
gone on the offensive when it comes to
gender issues and the metoo movement
claiming to
carry the torch for that this was very
uncomfortable for many members of the
party going forward
and increasingly untenable that said
he certainly left himself uh
uh open to future possibilities of of
running he didn't
discuss that directly but again did not
admit
uh that he had done anything illegal and
certainly
raised issue with the allegations that
had been made against him and the report
that had been filed against him calling
it political
but in terms of dragging this out in
state government said that it didn't
make sense and
at this point it looked like it was
going to be a losing battle for him
anyway and he
he did in fact see the writing on the
wall so
uh a rising star in the democratic party
now stepping down all right thanks very
much
kristen salumi live for us there in new
york
on the news that uh